establishing a mood from the get-go is
monumentally important for a movie
especially for films of the horror
thriller genre a movie's first few
scenes can either strike an audience
with terror or signal yawns to come
which is particularly scary for horror
fans in the case of these freaky flicks
the first 10 minutes are terrifying for
all the right reasons
a Nightmare on Elm Street the opening
credits for Wes Craven's a Nightmare on
Elm Street introduced Freddy Krueger
without showing his burn damaged face as
he puts together his terrifying claw in
his boiler room once his blades are
ready we meet victim number 1 Tina is a
pajama-clad blonde who finds herself
running down the halls of his leaky lair
all while Krueger cackles at the
uselessness of her escape attempt just
as she's about to eat it at the hands of
his new weapon she awakens to realize
it's all just a dream
judging by the slash marks on her gown
though we already know in the film's
first few moments that it's much worse
than some normal nightmare scream the
opening scene from scream was an instant
horror favorite and for good reason
Casey Becker is your everyday teen girl
cooking up some popcorn in her home
alone while her parents are out on a
date she gets a call from an apparent
prankster who wants to talk about scary
movies and Casey thinks it's all just
fun and games and plays along like scary
ha ha but then the conversation starts
to turn dark she quickly begins to
realize this isn't a joke especially
once the caller reveals he's abducted
her boyfriend Steve and bound him on her
back deck her fight-or-flight response
kicks in but the latter option isn't
available because the mask boogeyman has
gone from lurking outside to inside the
villain speed and ability to protect her
every move courtesy of the houses open
window scheme is absolutely crippling
making things worse when the killer
finally strikes Casey's parents have
come back home but she can't scream loud
enough for anyone to help her
now who hasn't had that nightmare before
jaws all Chrissy wanted to do was take a
little night swim with the cute guy she
met at a party while she's practically a
fish in the moonlit water the dude isn't
so convinced he's capable of swimming
he's pretty drunk after all so Chrissy
goes it alone and gets about halfway to
a buoy before that ominous cello music
kicks in Chrissy is all smiles in the
dark until something starts to pull her
under she's left thrashing and begging
for help
but her wannabe boyfriend is unaware on
the beach desperate she tries to cling
to the buoy but she knows she's done for
the shark drags her down and makes a
meal of the poor girl meanwhile mr.
helpful is still over there drunkenly
murmuring to himself in the sand talk
about a beach bum the ring when we first
meet Katie and Becca they're blabbering
about the woes of modern tech but one of
them is harboring a very dark secret
it's not the Elektra Ray's that pose a
threat to the girls it's the fabled
video tape que Diaz watch that's said to
kill anyone who watches it a week later
somehow she's not bothered by the
ominous warning label that was attached
to the tape or the fact that she's
received a frightening phone call soon
after her screening of it she even faked
jokes to show how unscared she is but
her playfulness comes to a halt once
things around the house start turning
themselves on and off and everything's
soaking wet all of a sudden when she
goes to find Becca she discovers the
video is playing in her room and she
gasps as her face turns to stone if
you've been hesitant to chuck that old
VCR well this might change your mind
final destination the first scene in
final destination set the shock value
bar pretty high for the film's to follow
in the beginning we meet Alex a high
school student who's boarding flight 180
with his school pals they're excited for
their field trip to Paris until all hell
breaks loose and the plane starts to
fall apart in midair killing some of the
passengers in grizzly ways before it
explodes and takes the rest then all of
a sudden
Alex wakes up in a cold sweat and
realizes it was just a dream he's
convinced this is some kind of
premonition that everyone needs to heed
but after screaming his warnings to the
rest of the passengers Alex is booted
from the plane along with a few unhappy
Tagalongs the group is also made to
eight in the airport as the plane takes
off for the excursion of a lifetime but
then Alex's vision comes true as the
plane blows up after the first film the
sequels tried to follow that explosive
formula with a massive highway pileup a
roller coaster ride gone wrong a race
car demolition derby and a devastating
bridge collapse so if you want to see
some movies that are front loaded with
massive intensity the final destination
movies are your well final destination
Night of the Living Dead in the
introduction to George Romero's seminal
zombie flick we meet Johnny and Barbara
a pair of siblings who've trekked out to
put a wreath on their dad's grave due to
technical problems with their radio they
don't hear the warning that's being
broadcast about what they're about to
encounter in the cemetery while Barb's
paying a respects
Johnny notices a weird man walking
through the graveyard and makes light of
the arrival they're coming for you
Barbra little does he know his joke has
just set the tone for everything that's
about to happen
barb tries to pass the stranger but he
reaches out and grabs her so Johnny
jumps to his sister's defense but he
snacked out cold while trying to wrestle
the man to the ground terrified Barbara
kicks off her shoes and runs away to
lock herself inside her car the walker
doesn't suffer windows though so barbara
releases the parking brake hoping she
can roll away to safety but a tree stops
her progress forcing her to flee on foot
when she enters an abandoned farmhouse
that seems relatively safe it's only the
beginning of her bout with this deadly
humanoid thing and many others to come
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]